hello reject nation the mic is on
I'm Greg Alva I'm Thailand Kyle Luhrmann
from the social media is fan theory
channel calm or YouTube type in sand
theory you'll get his channel if you
want to know if fan theories about
listen to the title you might get a clue
spider-man is his favorite comic book
character of all of human history this
is 100% answer so I said Kyle come by
today let's watch a couple of clips
because what better thing to do for a
spider-man movie then watch more footage
of it before the movie comes out am i
right
this is that am i right Washington
Monument fight
[Music]
No
[Music]
Namah handy
save him save him
whoa I would love it if he gets really
violent they all just died did you see
that though what I see what you see I
ran his Tony Stark has checked him out
so much that his webbing he actually can
set to down salt like ricochet off of
objects what do you mean look how his
webbing shoots out it shoots in an
l-shape when he fires out of his wrist
let's see right boom boom
what is that oh cool that's really
awesome
that's why you're here to notice [ __ ] I
don't know that was really neat hey I
got a theory
let's hear there's a clip called Nets
term where they're all going to the
decathlon in Washington something tells
me they're not going to be able to
attend that decathlon probably nothing I
put two and two together see I thought
okay here's what's going to happen when
I saw the clip I was like all right he's
going to go to the decathlon they're
going to go to Washington and then
something's going to go wrong
we're not going to be able to
participate in the decathlon or or or
they're going to go to the decathlon
peter is not going to be able to attend
cuz he knows something else is up his
spidey sense is going to go tingling
they're all going to be like Peter
wasn't able to make it
Peter puts it out so Michelle's like
looking for him like that over speed as
he spider-man and then BAM they're all
called the elevator he saves their lives
but they all still don't respect him
because they think he pussied out of
Calphalon yes so this is the one thing
about the trailers that I'm really
confused about so they're in Washington
DC and spider-man takes place generally
in New York yeah I've seen bait these
high school kids entered into the
catalog which is in washing I'm with you
there yeah but why is there this menace
of this threat happening so far from
home you mean vulture yeah because maybe
he wants to take down the government
what is the capital yeah that's just one
thing I'm really curious to see what the
plot is behind this whole like we're in
New York they're obviously on there on
some kind of field trip for school
that's like a club that they're all like
you said and so this happens with the
elevator now is it isn't the vulture or
is it something else
it could be shocker maybe that's how
they tie it together a very long movie
the incidence is that the incidences
that happened at Washington DC are seen
on the news and vulture may be
approached yet or maybe voltar hates
kids who compete in two catalogs that's
most likely and more likely I think
likely off and very sometimes I was mad
I really think I got accurate prediction
and down to a seat oh hey you know
there's another clip out there I think
we should watch that too let's do that
now most people would just milk it into
two separate videos why would I be smart
and do that and get more views that way
ya know you get higher quality and less
views but you know Kevin's Weddell out
he doesn't tell again if I already fell
out two to three times a month yeah when
you hear some product placement but
that's only a couple times and pocalypse
let's check out the next clip spider-man
versus vulture fight this is good this
is good I need more footage because I'm
evidently not sold on this movie yes
[Music]
whoa the new thing for him
whoa
[Music]
Kaizer web do cool things man I took
more IDs that's the cause of the ship to
explode Cogan is actually his fault
wow that's interesting oh crap so his
web-shooters have all different kinds of
things even when he first there's one
shot words like three Supper webs on
both hands yeah yeah yes lips I mean I
don't remember any kind of taser or any
kind of electricity going through the
going through the webbing in the comics
but they definitely as much as I hate to
reference this movie they did something
like that an amazing spider-man 2 um
arguably the best spider-man movie
around currently can't even pretend to
like when spider-man 3 I've heard some
complaints that people are like this
isn't what spider-man is Simon doesn't
have all these these trick webbing and
all this this stuff like when he had
some of that stuff I mean he like made a
shield and stuff like that yeah it was
actually less believable because it was
like he was just so skilled he would
just web quick you know I actually like
where the ideas behind how he does some
of this stuff comes from it makes sense
Tony Stark has upgraded all the Avengers
why not upgrade this new Avenger that's
sure if he gave Lord his powers Tony
started built the Infinity stones almost
there almost there yeah any man I know
he read the comics boy 11th reason I'm
alright with him having a you know
higher tech webbing stuff yeah because
of the fact that he's now in the MCU
yeah because we've gotten two separate
franchises that didn't finish outside of
the MCU so it's like why not make
spider-man now these included them MCU
more of like an MCU version of
spider-man after having updated web
technology from higher
man just make sense to me it doesn't
bother me that and people want something
new and different I think a lot of
people just like what we just don't want
to buy them anymore I'm like I get what
you're saying but this is the first time
ever a lot of people keep confusing
Marvel movies as Marvel studio movies
and it's not the same thing this is the
first time ever that spider-man is in
the MCU right and so it's a really big
deal and so yes I know it's so shortly
after amazing spider-man which was the
best rendition 11 anything I mean
they're taking all of the cool stuff
including the the web wings and
everything like they're doing the comic
book but they're doing it in a style
that's in in a more believable Iron Man
like universe and I think it totally it
makes perfect sense that they're doing
them and I love it because he can do so
many more cool things that you could
never do before
that's little ricochet webbing yeah it's
the coolest thing I think I've seen a
while
yes I'm wondering how I mean this seems
like well the rumor has it that I mean
it's more than a rumor Kevin Feige
pretty much spoke on it saying that
spider-man would be the thing to lead a
lot of face forward oh absolutely I mean
as long as Amy Pascal doesn't have much
control of it yeah absolutely
Amy Pascal is the brilliant mind behind
the amazing spider-man D she is this is
true no discredit this is true hmm if I
Davis Iron Man - what else did he look
at that is so good oh it's really hard
to keep a straight face with you Greg um
me too god I think it's a little weird
that they've given away so many trailers
for this movie it's not seen the
marketing for the other sweater
this is but like I feel like I've seen
every scene in the movie I'm still going
to see them super pumped but I just
don't know how it ends how does he
defeat the vulture yeah you know I don't
know these specifics of the final end
but my theory if you watch my fan theory
on this you will
see all of that great information over
at my channel so you can do that why'd
you say it all here and not worry about
people going here okay fine go watching
video the thing youtubers have to do if
you want to hear up camera cut can can't
block it now god [ __ ] them do I hear
more information Kyle series go to fan
theory check out his video on maybe I'll
put a link this bit for the link in the
description box yeah go check out his
specific video message me that because I
will forget I wouldn't because I don't
pay attention to what I'm editing know
we're going on here what's going on it's
impressive when you when you get away
with yeah yeah all this man is a
brilliant editor brilliant like Tom
cotton 45 seconds just cut out of the
video to this moment right subscribe is
real rejects click notification Bell to
be notified to subscribe buttons don't
do [ __ ] and Kyle is the Cuyler Minh all
across social media his YouTube channel
is called fan Theory that is one word
because Kyle does not know how to spell
so fan theory is one word and we're
going to talk about how he lost weight
on our patreon on my page so we don't
share a patreon the real reject vitro
share one with you know if you can do
that now bhindi number